[Music]
imagine being confined to a 10 by 10
foot room
in complete isolation no timekeeping
devices no phones no books nothing to
write on no windows
[Music]
psychologists say that fewer than three
days in a room like this can lead to
brain damage I will be staying in this
room for three days
clearly he's on the border of misery
[Music]
even in a city surrounded by people it's
possible to feel lonely or bored your
brain is like a hungry sponge it's
constantly absorbing information it
thrives when stimulated between
smartphones and books and movies and
friends and family thousands of
sensations are constantly going into our
heads but what if it all got cut off
what is boredom well it's believed to be
an emotion that's a less intense form of
disgust a visual representation of
emotions developed by robert plutchik
shows the ball on a wheel notice that
boredom shares a spoke with disgust and
loathing they are different intensities
of the same emotion
you see boredom pushes us away from low
stimulus situations because variety and
stimulation literally lead to
neurogenesis brain cell growth we are
here today doing what we do because
boredom has guided us toward greater and
greater challenges and bigger and more
complex brains so what is it like to be
deprived of the sensations and social
interactions so many of us take for
granted
a landmark study at Harvard and Virginia
universities found that students prefer
to experience physical pain over 15
minutes of boredom to demonstrate the
surprising lengths people will go to to
avoid boredom we brought in an
unsuspecting subject for what he
believes to be a focus group we begin by
introducing a set of stimuli one of
which is very unpleasant Oh dirty what
shocked the out of me our fake
focus test continues so let's start with
the shock button Jamison would you
choose to experience this again I don't
want to do that again why wouldn't you
cuz it shocked me it could still feel it
going down my farm now it's time for
Jameson's true test the test of boredom
you will be in the room for 30 minutes
please remain in your chair
feel free to re-experience the electric
shock button okay or not okay right at
the moment of truth when the only two
options are boredom or painful shock
which will our subject choose he's not
even looking at the button
it hasn't even been a minute yet and
already Jamison is Restless with nearly
a half hour to go and no other
stimulation in the room the shock button
is a tempting object to occupy Jameson's
mind
remember what Jamison said a few minutes
ago I don't want to do that again but
will he desire stimulation so strongly
he just goes ahead and pushes that
button
[Music]
it took exactly one minute and 57
seconds of boredom for Jameson's mind to
go from never again to sure I'll give
myself an electric shock to relieve
boredom sometimes stimulation any
stimulation is perceived as better than
none at all now this guy doesn't like
being bored but can he resist touching
it a second time
[Music]
we're social animals whether it's
another human or a volleyball or an
electric shock button you'll make
friends with whatever you need to
Jameson I'm Michael thanks for coming in
today so tell me a little bit about what
you've been up to here in this room I've
been sitting in this room with a button
yeah and despite saying I didn't want to
press it again I pressed it twice why I
just bored in this room I suppose really
yeah
did that hurt yes the hypothesis is that
when left alone with a very negative
stimulus people will go ahead and
re-experience it just because it's
something to do
[Music]
we dislike being bored so much sometimes
physical pain is preferable but
intentionally putting yourself into what
would seem to be the most boring
environment possible can be useful it's
called sensory deprivation psychologists
have conducted experiments on sensory
deprivation since the 1930s during the
Cold War the military used sensory
deprivation for both training and
interrogation in the 1970s the activity
became recreational with soundproof
light proof floatation tanks that keep
you buoyant with salt water that is the
same temperature as your body
all right so I'm on my way to a
subterranean float lab this company
sells sensory-deprivation this will be a
sort of training session for my three
days in isolation and I'm getting
guidance from an expert
hey Dominic how are you hey what's up
Michael you know Dominic Monaghan from
Lord of the Rings and the TV series lost
now this is your first time this is my
first time I'm a little nervous I've
never been alone without any stimulation
one of my favorite things about flowing
is there's nothing else going on okay I
can't see anything you can't hear
anything you can't do anything you just
have to look at you and for some people
that's scared it's like looking in a
mirror if you out this notation tank is
a really good way of getting in prepped
for the isolation chamber but I also
think he needs to be okay with the fact
that it's gonna put mass out of his
comfort zone
the mind is a good thing to lose every
so often all right let's take a peek oh
so this is the room this is where I will
be floating for the next hour alone with
nothing to do but listen to my thoughts
I'll see you on the other side
the mind is a good thing to lose every
so often you have to remind fear that
you're in the drivers drivers drivers
drivers hey Dominic pause it it was
really good yeah can we sit down let's
do it
my initial my initial thought my when I
lay down was wow this is buoyant and
then I just started thinking about
errands and tasks but at some point well
it was like dreams huh but my eyes were
open like those sort of like half dreams
you have either when you're about to
fall asleep or when you're waking out
that's when it gets interested you're
allowing your brain to be free you're
just floating in space you're just
actives that are on the top of this pool
floating in space
so now you've done this and you do this
this isolation booth delia that was in
some way helpful or hindrance it made me
more unhappy about what's coming up
three days is quite a bit different than
one hour
some people choose isolation to learn
about isolation as we prepare to explore
other planets were faced with a little
issue stuff in outer space is really
really far apart within our own solar
system
even a trip to Mars would take months in
each direction that's a long time to
spend cut off from the rest of humanity
stuck at a tiny spaceship to get ready
for those journeys we have subjected
some people to extreme conditions here
on earth in 1989 a young Italian
interior designer named Stefania Fellini
volunteered for a NASA experiment to
help study the effects of isolation
associated with space travel she spent a
hundred and thirty days alone in a
plexiglass cell in a cave 30 feet
underground in New Mexico in the absence
of timepieces and any sign of day or
night miss Fellini's body was thrown out
of whack her menstrual cycle stopped and
her sleep-wake cycle changed radically
she tended to stay awake for 20 to 25
hours at a time sleeping about 10 hours
when she finally emerged she mistakenly
believed she'd only been underground
about half as long as she actually had
as difficult as Stefani's experience was
at least she had books to read in my
isolation chamber I will only have white
walls to stare at
alone time what a pleasure
checking out getting away from it all
relaxing banishment from society the
silent treatment solitary confinement
solitude isn't always nice what happens
when isolation is not voluntary William
Brown has first-hand knowledge of
solitary confinement
so William how how much of your life
have you spent in prison probably like
16 years it's like almost half your life
yeah basically almost half my life
because I went to jail when I was 18 on
bank robbery this right here this is my
home off enough about two years though
was the longest stretch of consecutive
time I was like five months total I'll
tell you what really amazes me this
feels so much worse than a jail cell
this doesn't have bars letting in light
or a view not at all would you have a
mattress at least that would be the only
thing in this particular cell that would
be the only thing in here you would you
would just have a mattress and that you
would have nothing more this light will
constantly stay on so there would be you
know it's always on that light is always
been at night even at night that light
is always on your left in here with your
thoughts that's it
I would sit like like say friends I will
sit in this corner right here like based
in the corner facing out no I won't face
out and I will just sit and just
concentrate on breathing you don't know
it's like you're in the limbo hey you
never know when I got over the door I've
known guys that have served consecutive
years inside this same little box how
does that change them mentally it's cars
them for life really yeah this is what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna put myself in a
room like one of these and I won't have
a clock anything at all no way to tell
time what I'm nervous about is when that
door closes and the awareness the sudden
awareness of how much time I have
see that's the thing about it cuz once
this door right here closes it's like
it's it's final this is almost a coffin
really
even more extreme than isolation from
other people is isolation from other
people and stimuli that's what I'm going
to be doing inside this room this is
about as boring as a room can get it's
soundproof and this light will never
turn off I do have a small bed but there
will be no interruptions I will have no
way to tell what time it is no meals
will be delivered because all the meals
are inside the room already white
containers of Soylent I do have plenty
of water and I have a wash basin with a
white bar of soap and I've got myself a
tiny little toilet there's nothing to do
but be completely alone with myself and
my thoughts now psychologists say that
fewer than three days in a room like
this can lead to brain damage I will be
staying in this room for three days a
full 72 hours
so I'm gonna take your vitals first
Michael is basically turning himself
into a lab rat what we want to do is see
what might change with Michael before
and after his time in isolation what's
gonna happen to his blood pressure
what's gonna happen to his pulse his
basic reflexes are there actually any
medical concerns you would have I'm just
gonna be in this room you got a really
bright light on there the circadian
rhythm which is your natural wake and
sleep cycle is going to be completely
disrupted by this really bright light
and once your circadian rhythm gets off
a lot of other things fall apart hormone
cycles
cognitive ability metabolic processes so
you know it's kind of like you're giving
yourself jetlag how great I think it's
important to test his cognitive ability
to gauge any mental decline that might
happen during at 72 hours of isolation
let's try the reaction time okay dude
this is pretty fun can I bring this into
the room with me so what's gonna happen
to my brain in there well one of the
issues that might worry me is how calm
versus neurotic you might be where would
you put yourself on that spectrum closer
to neurotic coming on yeah so I wonder
if that might be amplified that is how
my brain will work it'll snowball
I'm scared I'm not gonna be able to deal
with the monotony and the lack of a
sense of time and I'm gonna have a panic
attack in an extreme situation people
can have massive hallucinations
disassociated from reality have
tremendous anxiety psychotic types of
episodes Marty Jake yes I'm gonna be
gone for three days the danger signs to
look out for are extreme agitation where
it doesn't appear that he's aware of his
own agitation that's when I think I
might intervene I'm not worried for him
physically like I think he's you know
he's safe in there but I think that he's
gonna struggle in there he's gonna be
really bored
love you bye-bye
[Music]
by
forgot to ask what time it was when I
came in
she's always doing something reading
something talking to someone the or day
looks really bored in this making their
five offenders it's just gonna be a
horrible 72 hours I'm actually pretty
tired I've been standing a bunch today
normally when I change into more
comfortable clothes and I'm like ready
for bed I lay down and then I pick up my
phone or a pick up a book or something
but I don't even I don't have that if he
succeeds in going to sleep for any
length of time that's substantial that's
gonna be interesting to see it what time
he thinks it is when he wakes up right
I was able to sleep and I woke up maybe
one or two times in the night so I think
it's probably you know 8 a.m. Thursday
morning maybe closer to 9 a.m. I guess I
should have some breakfast
one two three
I've known Michael for three years and
I've never seen him do a push-up zy x w
vu t sr q p o n MLK I think he's come up
with some some good ideas for mental
stimulation I wonder if it's time goes
by he's gonna come up with some more
creative ones or he's gonna start to get
less creative I've done 200 steps now
eight more hundreds to go and I'll be at
a thousand why is it that so many people
turn to counting to stay saying when
they're in these isolated environments
well our our minds want to remain active
there they're naturally active the
healthiest people who survive in these
types of environments will do something
to self stimulate they'll count they'll
sing they'll do physical exercise one
hundred three hundred steps and then
some change that I just took right there
that's just a little bonus for my body
for my health
it's amazing how hard it is to tell what
time of day it is just based on your
body I think it's about 7:00 or 7:30
p.m. on Thursday I think I'm gonna have
dinner now he's already quite off on his
perception of time I was actually
surprised at how quick that happened I
was too you know if you're using hunger
as your gauge that's out the window too
because the shifts and hormones are
going to change your appetite now they
look at lab rats who have had their
circadian rhythm destroyed and they
overeat
13 at the moment I'm feeling bored but
obviously nothing dramatic if I had to
guess it would be 24 hours now since I
first came in one day down two to go
if he gets a full sleep cycle in he'll
wake up not knowing where he is
right good morning I don't know if I
slept for eight hours or if I slept for
three if you think it's bedtime it is so
long as you go to bed if you think it's
breakfast time it is if you're having
breakfast what am I looking forward to
the most
seeing my my family and friends it's not
even that I want a meal it's actually
that I just want to have a meal with
people I just want to talk to some
people I just want some other words
coming in to me than the ones that come
out of my own mouth he enjoys sharing
things with people and to have no one
there's nothing coming back for three
days might be difficult I am the only
person I'm hanging out with if you're in
true isolation literally part of your
brain is generating some kind of
companion converse with I think having
you here makes a big difference
you know he's entertained himself in a
sense you know talking to the camera and
that's been helpful for him it's really
kept him cognitively aware I just feel
like I've really lost all connection to
time but I'm guessing it's you know 8
p.m. maybe 9 p.m. on Friday a good time
to get some some shut-eye when there's
not much else to do
[Music]
I think it's Saturday about 9:00 a.m.
Saturday the day I get out so his
dissociation with the actual time has
doubled now right he wakes up and
there's this bright light and he's
thinking oh it must be morning I've
spent a lot of time to being entertained
by my memories and I'm thinking of the
people and the places and the events and
how I missed them and how I treasure
those moments there's a sort of cinema
in my brain a cinema of those memories
that's kept me from being very bored so
I think it's 8 p.m. on Saturday so in
about a couple hours I should see that
door open he's not even close and I
wonder how he's gonna respond to that
[Music]
I don't think I'm getting out today a
fear I have right now is that it's just
Friday and if there's still a lot of
time left there are other times during
this that I was definitely more Zen
about everything now I'm upset I can't
believe the color of the light isn't
changing in the mornings when I wake up
it's so much more yellow without some
type of stimulation the mind wants to
stimulate itself anyway and will begin
to hallucinate and begin to play all
sorts of tricks absolutely
my thoughts are really incoherent there
it's hard for me to even to remember
what I just thought in 712 713 714 715 7
fifteen 716 717 70 in a way our brains
are kind of uh use it or lose it thing
he's going to have a definite decrease
in his cognitive ability a decrease in
his overall sense of well-being
how many bottles of water if I drink is
there one more
laying around here that I've lost
because there are only six here but then
down here there are did I
[Music]
all of the dreams I've had that I
remember have been about this room
they've been about me being in this room
and about
he wakes up in these in the room it's
difficult for him to discern the
difference between reality and dreaming
sometimes so that's a real dissociation
for him sr q LMNOP worried about him now
because when he first went in there he
was like bored like someone waiting for
a bus you know now he looks actually
depressed the soap is really unique it's
not a kind of soap I've ever used before
and I really dislike the smell and I
keep smelling it because it's just
sitting there clearly Michael is not
happy right now he he looks like you
know on the border of misery really
aggravated by how uncomfortable I am
this seems like a very very long three
days
[Music]
he was just laying there when I walked
in I thought he'd be you know city like
bed you know this was something he
wanted to do but I expected him to be
bored terribly bored but I thought he'd
still be talking and trying to entertain
himself
[Music]
it seems like Michael woke up from some
kind of dream he looks confused
[Music]
I'm really confused
we did I guess not I guess I just dreamt
it I am so confused
[Music]
is 72 hours over it's 72 hours Michael
you can come out all right I'm coming
out oh my gosh it's bright in there it's
really bright in there I hadn't really
noticed but now that you mention it
we're outdoors hey that knock scared me
did it startle you yeah every little
noise has been startling me okay you
seem very with it right now it's excited
energy yeah
like coming out at first I thought it
was that I want to communicate but
actually I need this direction too even
if it's just nods and stuff that's so
much better
let me just check your vitals before you
see your family 155 over 95 so that's
quite a jump in your blood pressure
[Music]
your pulse is also higher I think that's
because you're excited to be out I think
this is a huge rush I'm interested to
see now how you do with some of the more
cognitive tests three 18:09 seven -
seven - there you go I would say you did
actually a little bit better this time
oh wow
okay although we had AI pathi sized you
would be worse at all of these tests
I think the rush of adrenaline that you
got from finally being out and being
able to communicate actually had you
more focused more aware and that's why
you performed better I find it
interesting that the tests you did the
worst on is probably the most to do with
the use of the verbal language and
you've had definitely a lack of that
over the last 72 hours it was just me
with myself for three days it was only
me how are you oh good I missed you let
me say hi to my mom Oh glad you served
right yes in the room I was fine being
alone this is what I've been living but
then near the end as I started to
anticipate coming out and and being able
to talk to people and share my
experience I realized how important that
was if you only have your own
experiences you're not fully having them
you have to have someone else to listen
to them and react to them and then
you've fully experienced them anyway I
I've moved I don't live there anymore
when I was in isolation I was surprised
most by two things how easy it was to be
separated from distractions like
entertainment and phones and how
difficult it was to be separated from
things we humans evolved alongside the
earth and other people I was amazed by
how uncomfortable confusing and scary it
was to have nothing but myself you know
I used to be a really big fan of the
Seine he who travels fastest travels
alone I think I liked it because it made
me feel better about how I preferred to
be independent and to be left to my own
devices but now I appreciate the full
phrase better it may be true that he who
travels fastest travels alone but he who
travels furthest travels with others and
as always thanks for watching
this season on minefield
[Music]
ready ready hold the drug in your mouth
until we say swallow
they've been some audio-visual
distortions we see some images behind
your eyes how does it feel to be known
as the Ken and Barbie of real life it
isn't a breakfast for champions it's a
breakfast for sheeple bachelor number
two is an online chat
beautiful
welcome to minefield
[Music]